ya hemos visto que una enzima ayuda a
catalizar una reacción así que digamos
que esta de aquí es nuestra enzima y
tenemos nuestro sustrato y va y se une
al sitio activo de la enzima vamos a
decir que el sustrato se une justo ahí
en la enzima en lo que llamamos el sitio
activo y luego la enzima cataliza una
reacción tal vez rompe este sustrato en
dos moléculas más pequeñas y así después
de la reacción la enzima no se modifica
pero una reacción ha sido catalizada
ahora tenemos el sustrato que está
dividido en este caso al menos en dos
moléculas más pequeñas
voy a dibujarlos esta es una de ellas y
esta es la otra por aquí así que solo
salieron del sitio activo una vez que se
cataliza la reacción ya no tienen
afinidad por el sitio activo y se rompen
así que esta enzima acaba de catalizar
esta reacción
de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
como esto puede ser inhibido y
específicamente como podría ser inhibido
competitivamente así que vamos a hablar
acerca de la inhibición competitiva
déjame escribirlo por aquí
inhibición
división
competitiva inhibición competitiva así
que el caso clásico de inhibición
competitiva es cuando hay alguna
molécula que compite con el sustrato por
el sitio activo y esta no es la única
forma de inhibición competitiva pero
este es el que verás más comúnmente en
un libro de texto así que aquí tenemos a
nuestra enzima de nuevo y ya hemos visto
que este de aquí es el sitio activo
sitio activo
y si la molécula nuestro sustrato llega
al sitio activo vamos a tener este
primer escenario pero en la inhibición
competitiva o al menos en la versión que
voy a mostrar en este momento podrías
tener otra molécula que se ve algo así
que puede competir por el sitio activo y
si llega al sitio activo primero déjame
mostrarte lo que va a pasar tenemos aquí
nuestra enzima tenemos la otra molécula
que no es nuestro sustrato y que se une
al sitio activo primero y ahora nuestro
sustrato aquel para el cual la enzima
cataliza la reacción no puede unirse y
la reacción no va a suceder y se puede
ver muy claramente que están compitiendo
por la enzima y en este caso están
compitiendo por el sitio activo ahora
bien esta no es la única forma de
inhibición competitiva otra forma de
inhibición competitiva es la inhibición
competitiva a los tehrik a
déjame escribir eso
inicial
competitiva
a los tehrik a inhibición competitiva a
los teórica
un sitio a los tehrik o es un sitio
distinto del sitio activo en la
inhibición competitiva a los tehrik a el
competidor se ha une a un sitio que no
es el sitio activo es un sitio a los
tehrik o así que el competidor se podría
unir aquí que claramente no es el sitio
activo así que tal vez el competidor se
ve algo así no se unió al sitio activo
pero al unirse aquí nuestro sustrato el
sustrato deseado ya no puede unirse al
sitio activo por lo que tiene el mismo
efecto tenemos el mismo efecto aquí
donde el sustrato no se va a poder unir
pero si esto se une primero voy a
dibujar ahora este escenario así que si
nuestro sustrato deseado se une primero
entonces el competidor no puede unirse
así que en este caso si el sustrato es
capaz de llegar al sitio activo entonces
el competidor no se puede unir así que
una vez más están compitiendo voy a
dibujar al competidor aquí el que llegue
primero obtiene la enzima en esta
situación el competidor no se puede unir
esto es válido si se está hablando de la
inhibición competitiva donde están
compitiendo por el sitio activo
y si el competidor llega primero el
sustrato previsto no va a llegar y la
reacción no va a ser catalizada si el
sustrato destinado llega primero
entonces el competidor no va a ser capaz
de unirse de hecho podría haberse dado
esta situación donde debido a que el
sustrato llegó primero el competidor no
va a ser capaz de unirse al sitio activo
cuando estamos hablando de una
inhibición competitiva a los tehrik a
todavía estamos compitiendo por la
enzima solo uno va a conseguir unirse si
uno llega primero a la enzima entonces
el otro no va a ser capaz de unirse
ellos están compitiendo por la enzima
pero el competidor el que no es nuestro
sustrato se une a un sitio a los tehrik
o mediante la unión del competidor al
sitio a los técnicos se cambia la
conformación de la enzima de modo que el
sitio activo y el sustrato deseado ya no
se pueden unir y quiero realmente
enfatizar este punto porque cuando
estaba aprendiendo esto a menudo me
pareció algo confuso incluso hay algunos
sitios que puedes encontrar en internet
que van a decir que este tipo de
inhibición la inhibición competitiva a
los erika la van a llamar de tipo no
competitiva porque no se está
compitiendo por el sitio activo sin
embargo este no es el caso en la
inhibición no competitiva y voy a hacer
el siguiente vídeo acerca de la
inhibición no competitiva en la
inhibición no competitiva el inhibidor
se puede unir independientemente de si
el sustrato está unido o no pero cuando
el inhibidor se une evita que la
reacción continúe cambian la
conformación de la proteína por lo que
ya no puede catalizar la reacción así
que en la inhibición no competitiva
ambos pueden unirse pero si el inhibidor
está unido
la reacción no va a proceder en la
inhibición competitiva ya sea que
estemos hablando de la inhibición
competitiva a los teórica o de la
inhibición competitiva no a los teórica
solamente uno de ellos el sustrato
ahora va a ser capaz de unirse ellos
están compitiendo por la enzima